for a Disney film Hercules manages to
slip in quite a few jokes and
pop-culture references that could easily
go unnoticed by younger audiences from
Disney Easter eggs to mythological
origins here's a list of the things only
adults will notice when watching
Disney's Hercules Greek mythology isn't
exactly kid-friendly there's plenty of
death despair extramarital affairs
drinking cannibalism and an array of
terrifying monsters that would give most
children nightmares with this in mind it
makes sense that the film had to take
liberties regarding the actual legend of
Hercules the film shows Zeus and Hera as
being in a healthy loving relationship
however this couldn't be further from
the case in mythology Zeus has a
reputation for cheating on his wife with
an extensive list of women a fact that
Hera is well aware of and resents about
her husband Hercules is an even Harris
son according to mythology in fact
Hercules wasn't born to two divine
parents instead he's the child of Zeus
and the mortal woman Alka Meena the main
reason this change was made in the film
is likely because Hera is behind
Hercules hardships in the original story
not Hades like in the movie era resents
Hercules and as a result tries to have
him killed
additionally Megara is most likely a
combination of two characters from
mythology
Megara and Hercules second wife
deianeira in a grim turn of events
Hercules actually kills Megara in the
original myth so much for happily ever
after and Hercules the city of Thebes
otherwise known as the big olive is a
major metropolis known for its high
energy and hustle and bustle basically
Thebes is one giant New York stereotype
from the pita bread carts to the
Doomsday graffiti smeared around the
city walls
Thebes reflects many aspects of the Big
Apple itself for better and for worse
much like New York Thebes and all of its
inhabitants are always in motion
there are chariots blazing back and
forth while pedestrians wait at what
appear to be ancient crosswalks large
crowds abound and Hercules is clearly
overwhelmed by the city environment when
Hercules and company first arrived they
nearly find themselves trampled by a
chariot driver only to be saved by Phil
who's more seasoned in navigating the
hectic city enraged by the rude driver
the satyr yells
a stereotypical New Yorker accent along
with the reference to the Manhattan set
movie Midnight Cowboy further cements
the connection to modern New York much
like New York thebes also has a bit of a
shady side as well like hercules who's
never set foot in a big city before at
one point the gang is approached by a
man in an oversized trenchcoat who at
first glance seems to flash the
unsuspecting group however this is a
Disney flick so the flasher is actually
just a sundial salesman with his stock
hidden beneath his coat in one scene
hercules is seen wearing a lion skin for
many viewers this wouldn't raise any
eyebrows especially since the lion is
likely a nod to the Nemean lion the
first of the 12 labors that Hercules had
to face in the original mythology
however more seasoned Disney fans may
notice something a little too familiar
about the ferocious feline from the
uniquely brown fur and black mane to the
scar under the big cat's eye the lion
looks exactly like scar from The Lion
King
he'd make a very handsome throw rug
overall it's a bit uncomfortable to see
Hercules and Phil thoughtlessly parading
around the lifeless body of another
Disney character on screen while this is
undoubtedly a clever nod to another
popular Disney title the implications
are rather dark in this universe Skaar
was killed and then skinned for his fur
coat which is definitely a morbid end
for the recognizable villain at the
beginning of the film all of the gods
and goddesses gather at Mount Olympus to
celebrate the birth of Zeus and Hera
snoo born son Hercules the various
deities are lounging around talking
drinking from fancy glasses and enjoying
each other's company as the crowd
partakes in the joyous celebration
Hermes zips through the scene and
comments to Zeus I haven't seen this
much love in a room since narcissus
discovered himself this joke is a nod to
the Greek myth narcissus narcissus was a
man of unparalleled beauty who spurned
the advances of the nymph Ecco this
earned narcissus the wrath of the gods
who made the man fall in love with his
own reflection as he gazed into a pool
of water narcissists unable to have his
obsessive love with himself reciprocated
eventually died of starvation as he
stared at his reflection after his date
with Meg Hercules raves about the play
the pair just saw that
and a [ __ ] I thought I had problems the
pair must have seen a performance of
Sophocles Oedipus Rex and Athenian
tragedy you wouldn't expect to pop up in
a Disney title in the play Oedipus
unknowingly kills his father King Laius
and becomes the king of Thebes
aside from killing his own father once
crowned King Oedipus unknowingly marries
his mother and father several children
considering the dark themes and Oedipus
Rex it's definitely a strange title to
be referenced in a children's animated
film meg is beloved for her sassy
attitude and sly remarks that set her
apart from many Disney leading ladies
however what actually makes Meg stand
out among the Disney Princesses isn't
just her saucy personality but her
experiences in the dating arena Disney
loves to focus on happily ever after
endings and as a result many Disney
characters have optimistic and slightly
naive views of love this is mainly
because prior to their love interest in
their respective film they haven't dated
at all Meg on the other hand hasn't only
dated other men before Hercules
she's been outwardly betrayed by the man
she loved at the cost of her own freedom
as a result meg has a far more realistic
and at times pessimistic view of love
and men a prime example of this is after
Hercules saves her from nessus she tells
him well you know how men are they think
no means yes and get lost means take me
on yours it's because of her negative
experiences that meg has trouble warming
up to Hercules her entire song I won't
say I'm in love
shows her struggling to embrace her
feelings without losing her common sense
and falling prey to another bad
relationship for a Disney lead meg is
undoubtedly a far cry from the typical
doe-eyed adventure seeker and that's why
she's still so popular to this day in
the film Hercules the muses are the
film's narrators that guide viewers
through the narrative their songs also
allow for a natural passage of time
between significant events in the film
using the muses as narrators is a smart
modern adaption of the goddess from
mythology who presided over the arts but
aside from this adaptation of the
characters there's another connection to
ancient Greek theater ancient Greek
theater would have looked very different
from a production of the Phantom of the
Opera one of the most significant
differences in the structure was in how
the characters were written in addition
to having roles for the main characters
ancient Greek theater also frequently
employ
a group of actors to serve as onstage
narrators this group was the chorus and
they usually had one member who was the
chorus leader so to have the gospel
style course of singers also occupy the
role of the Greek chorus in this film is
an interesting blend of both mythology
and ancient Greek entertainment after
the fates prophesied that Hercules will
destroy Hades plans of overthrowing Zeus
Hades realizes that for his evil plan to
take flight he'll have to kill baby
Hercules he then sends pain and panic
his two bumbling sidekicks who almost
immediately botched the entire operation
instead of having Hercules ingest the
entire bottle of poison they were given
they mess up turning him mortal instead
so then what to pain in panic do they
leave Hercules for two mortal humans to
raise even worse they neglect to tell
Hades that Hercules isn't dead so
imagine Hades surprised when he finds
Hercules grown up and saving damsels in
the woods but really Hades can't place
all of the blame on pain and panic it's
confusing as to why Hades left such an
essential task to his minions in the
first place more confusing is why he
never even bothered to verify that the
job was completed presumably he can see
for himself each soul that enters the
underworld without having to leave the
comfort of home shouldn't he have been
on standby to make sure pain and panic
didn't mess things up this is pretty
lazy behavior from someone who wants to
become the king of Mount Olympus the
allusions to modern life in Hercules
show that life in ancient Greece wasn't
so different from life today well at
least in Disney's version of ancient
Greece anyway for example as a new soul
enters Hades realm there's a number
counter that says over five billion one
served mimicking McDonald's which
proudly advertised billions and billions
served that's one of the earliest modern
references in the film but it surely
isn't the last later when pain and panic
are pretending to be children trapped
under a boulder in an obvious parallel
to 911 one of them shouts
one of the best places to find these
modern references is during the film's
musical numbers during fill song one
last hope there's a training montage
where Phil Hercules and Pegasus are all
standing on pillars training in front of
a sunset this is a callback to the
training montage in the Karate Kid there
are also a ton of references in the song
zero to hero one of the more fleeting
examples is when the movie shows the
line outside of Hercules store and we
see two shops located on either side of
the building these stores are named
Aphrodite secret and column and barrel
alluding to Victoria's Secret and Crate
and Barrel respectively the song also
features more nods to the modern day
such as the Grecian Express card the air
Herc sandals and the Hercule drink the
film's most prominent and easily
recognizable reference to real world art
is likely the venus de milo from which
hercules removed the arms while on his
date with meg but sharp-eyed viewers
will find multiple examples of classical
art and architecture scattered
throughout before hercules begins his
journey he has an incident at the Agora
resulting in its destruction though the
construction is slightly different the
architecture bears a striking
resemblance to st. Peter's Square in
Rome after this socially traumatizing
incident Hercules talks to his adoptive
parents where another bit of ancient art
can be found looking at the interior
design of their home the wall design
looks like Akrotiri spring fresco or is
at least partly inspired by it another
example of ancient architecture can be
seen in go the distance as hercules
enters the temple of zeus sitting tall
is a colossal stone likeness of the
thunder god which comes to life to tell
his son about the necessity of becoming
a true hero the actual temple used to
house a reasonably similar statue though
the historical monument was accented
with a gold staff not seen in the film
finally the last easily recognizable art
reference appears during the song I
won't say I'm in love when Meg walks
past the muses standing as pillars in
reference to the caryatids of the
Acropolis while the real caryatids are
grander in scale
they certainly lack a similar musicality
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you